they have really aggressive projections
they want to
grow uh double revenue by 2023 you know
doubling revenue in three or four years
you divide that into 72 the rule of 72
there have to be
15 20 growth every year and you know
they were at 7
so that's 10 years to double revenue so
now they've set a much more ambitious
goal
that means they're going to need to have
either more advertising twice as much
advertising charge twice as much for it
have twice as many users
or have another revenue stream that
contributes to this so they're obviously
doing all of those things and getting
aggressive they set a goal to double
development velocity by the end of 2023
i think they're getting there already
they really want to do that to drive the
monetizable daily active users or
revenue right
and you know 199 is nice but they're
well behind
other platforms facebook has about 14
times as many
uh daily uh users and facebook's
quarterly revenue is 25 times that of
twitter so
that's pretty uh aggressive twitter is
aiming to grow their
monetizable daily active users to just
315 million so
they've only got to add 150 million i
think that's possible uh with a lot of
these subscription products because
you know if you have patreon only fans
you know
paid youtube you you as a content
creator are then going to
ask people to come to some location to
engage that location was only fans
twitch
clubhouse sub stack patreon
now you're going to tell them to come to
twitter i'm going to say go to
twitter.com
jason and subscribe or
somebody like lizzo might say go to
twitter.comlizzo and
subscribe and see my you know
you know me doing acoustic versions of
my songs at home whatever she does like
some cool stuff on tick tock like that
uh will she'll sing and interact with
fans so really interesting
to see this aggressive and you know
twitter had a stagnant share price for a
long time they ipo in 2013
under dick costello who is now an
investor a great guy um and they were at
a 31 billion dollar market cafe after a
brief surge so 60 bucks a share twitter
dropped back to 40 and traded flat into
2015 then it dipped to 30 dollars a
share
and this was you know i think pretty
rattling for a lot of twitter insiders
and shareholders a lot of them
sold their shares back then and twitter
traded down bottomed out of 14
a share in 2017. jack in 2018
reorganized
and the market started to respond a lot
of people like
professor galloway were saying you know
jack should be fired
i believe and and then twitter got to 40
a share for the first time since it's
ipo
trade flat and then they peaked uh in
february of this year at 77
after this aggressive projections were
uh released
and now they're at 51 a share in a 40
billion dollar market cap
for it to be at 40 billion is is really
disappointing in a way because their
influence is much higher
if you look at their revenue by year
2012
300 2013 they doubled to 600 2014
they two and a half times to 1.4 billion
or almost two and a half times then from
2014 to 2015 they go from 1.4 to 2.2
yeah it's a 50 growth not bad and then
here we go
the brakes start to pump 2015 to 2016
only to 2.5 2017 they go down to 2.4 but
then trump gets elected
and we have a storing economy and the
product
maybe starts getting a little bit better
but i would say trump and the soaring
economy
you know really boost interest in
twitter and they go 2.4
to 3 billion in 2018 to 3.4 billion in
2019 to 3.7 billion in 2020.
those are nice jumps but again you're
talking about high single digits low
double digits
and so this is uh also dovetails because
it's only advertising and advertising is
fickle during a great economy
or surging usage you get more ads in a
down market you get crushed
which is why people who were dependent
on advertising like the new york times
built their subscription businesses over
the last couple of years so they don't
have to worry about these wild swings
well now we have apple saying we're
going to let users opt out
or force them to opt in to being tracked
this is making
advertising on mobile phones with the
most elite group of people
iphone users basically it's it's ankling
a lot of it and we're going to go back
to a cpm model perhaps
charging per thousand impressions but
it's not gonna be as highly targeted
96 of users opted out of ad tracking
uh according to the flurry analytics
which is owned by verizon which
just got out of the content and
advertising business they literally
sold uh aol yahoo to
hedge fund and we might see some other
things like um bring your own algorithm
which jack talked about
that uh he might want to let people
bring their own way of sorting
after the whole section 230 hearings
back in the day
so will twitter what will twitter's
revenue be in 2023 can they
double it i think they can i think they
could double it yeah i could see them
acquiring more companies with revenue
i could see this vision coming true i
can see them falling short sure
it's going to be an aggressive goal they
could also see them exceeding it
and they seem to have the right team in
place they seem to be making great
acquisitions
and they seem a little more bold and
aggressive and the company's always been
passive
they've always been afraid to change
what's working
and this is a lesson for founders you
know you really do want to be careful
to not change the core user interface
because
that can confuse people and really upset
them look at amazon
it's ugly craigslist ugly ebay
ugly and then if you try to make them
you know elegant and new
people get really upset and they they go
why did you change it i can't find
stuff there is something when you're
doing transactions or you're building a
cms
or any kind of web service to
consistency
and not moving stuff around but that
means you could
have somebody disrupt you and it's
fantastic to see
twitter really um
getting better at product and increasing
the velocity
and being bold congratulations to the
team at twitter i think you're doing a
great job as a as a power twitter user
and somebody who loves the platform
and obviously has been talking about it
incessantly for you know going on uh two
decades now
i really love the changes and i wish you
the best to the twitter team it's
really impressive work we'll see you all
next time bye bye